now from the Cato Institute in
Washington DC the discussion on the life
of journalists HL Mencken you'll hear
from Terry Teachout author of the
sceptic sure is about one hour see
myself seated on a platform next to PJ
O'Rourke I know not to try any funny
stuff so I'll leave the punchlines to
him sooner or later usually sooner
anyone who proposes to write a book
about HL Mencken finds his way to the
top floor of the main branch of the
Enoch Pratt free library in downtown
Baltimore
on that floor is a room with a bright
blue door and behind that door are most
of the private papers of a vain and
brilliant packrat Mangum thought so well
of himself that he started subscribing
to a clipping service at the age of 23
and he preserved for the edification of
future generations of scholars among
many many other things his school books
his doctor's bills and all his canceled
checks
thanks to Mankins vanity or foresight
the Menken room also houses more than
200 scrapbooks containing every
newspaper and magazine article written
about HL Mencken since 1903 the earliest
clippings were dated and pasted into
those books by Menken himself I've read
them all or at least laid eyes on every
page which isn't quite the same thing
still I probably know as much about what
other people thought of Menken and wrote
about him is anybody alive and one thing
I've noticed is that since 1956 the year
he died an amazingly high percentage of
the clippings in the Menken scrapbooks
or what I call em Watts that's short for
if Menken were alive today in what it's
a literary form as strict as a sonnet
first the author describes some current
outrage against common sense that is his
version of common sense then in quick
succession he imagines the scalding
things Menken might have had to say
about it besides a few other recent in
similar offense
suggests the world would be a better
place in what then closes by remarking
that no modern-day newspaper would dare
hire so politically incorrect columnist
I saw a near-perfect example of an M
watt last week the first paragraph of
the Washington Post review of the
skeptic written by Richard lingman
Theodore Dreiser's biographer and a
senior editor of the nation who
weathered to my surprise liked my book
lingman wrote what if by some devilish
miracle the great 1920s iconoclast
HL Mencken were resurrected and writing
today who'd be the targets of his
cynical wit Jerry Falwell John Ashcroft
Ken Lay and the Enron gang George W Bush
oh well it's a pleasant thought and
there you have it the quintessence of
him what one of the reasons M wants are
so easy to write is because Menken was
so incredibly prolific between 1910 in
1941 he turned out at least one opinion
column every week as a result anyone
passively familiar with his work can
knock together in my it's stuffed with
quotations that have an unnerving ly
contemporary ring I place in evidence
this little Rhapsody about the American
politician written in 1926 he is a man
who has lied and dissembled and a man
who has crawled he knows the taste of
the boot polish he has suffered kicks in
the tunnel of his pantaloons
he has taken orders from his superiors
in knavery and he has wooed and
flattered his inferiors incensed his
public life is an endless series of
evasions and false pretenses he is
willing to embrace any issue however
idiotic that will get him votes and he
is willing to sacrifice any principle
however sound that will lose them for
him I do not describe the Democratic
politician at his inordinate worst I
describe him as he is encountered in the
full sunshine of normalcy he may be on
the one hand a crossroads idler striving
to get into the state legislature by
grace of the local mortgage sharks and
angelical clergy or he may be on the
other President of the United States it
is almost an axiom that no man may make
a career in politics in the Republic
without stooping to such ignoble 'ti it
is as necessary as a loud voice like I
said it's easy too easy in fact because
there is something about Menken that we
have a way of forgetting he is not our
contemporary we forget that because he
sounds so very contemporary not just in
tone but quite often in subject matter
as well kenneth tynan the english drama
critic once paid a lovely tribute to
Noel Coward he said even the youngest of
us will know in 50 years time exactly
what we mean by a very no coward sort of
person
well Tainan wrote those those words
exactly fifty years ago and sure enough
he was right we do HL Mencken died 46
years ago the week before I was born as
a matter of fact and today a
half-century later you can take it
pretty much for granted that any
literate American will know just what
you mean by a very HL Mencken sort of
essay what he'll probably have in mind
is something like oh maybe the
husbandman a little editorial about the
American farmer that Menken wrote for
the third issue of the american mercury
the magazine he co-founded in 1924 this
is how it starts let the farmers so far
as I am concerned to be damned for
evermore
to hell with him and bad luck to him he
is a tedious fraud and ignoramus a cheap
rogue and hypocrite the eternal jack of
the human pack he deserves all that he
ever suffers under our economic system
and more any city man not insane who
sheds tears for him is shedding tears of
the crocodile see what I mean of course
you do I can tell from the smiles on
your faces nobody else could have
written that paragraph and anybody who
knows anything about American literature
would have guessed who wrote it with a
few minor changes it would sound
perfectly fresh were you to see it on
the op-ed page
of tomorrow morning's paper and yet that
freshness is an illusion for we are as
far removed from the world of Menken's
youth as he was from the world of George
Washington he was born in 1880 ten
months before Billy the Kid was shot the
same year Edison invented the electric
light bulb he finished his schooling
went to work and began to publish before
the close of the 19th century he once
told a reporter that the only modern
innovations he truly appreciated where
the typewriter in the Pullman sleeper he
never flew on an airplane and for most
of his life he never drove a car never
went to the movies never listened to the
radio and used the telephone as seldom
as possible I shudder to think what he
would have thought of email not only was
making a man entirely of his own time in
place he was far more complicated than
many people realize including some of
his biggest fans on the surface he was
the clearest and most confident of
writers a paragon of self assurance in
1930 he was invited to contribute his
personal credo to a symposium whose
other participants included Albert
Einstein john dewey hg wells in bertrand
russell being a journalist and thus
accustomed to writing short he got the
whole of it into these three crisp
sentences i believe that it is better to
tell the truth than to lie i believe
that it is better to be free than to be
a slave and i believe that it is better
to know than to be ignorant
that's the crater without shadows or
second thoughts no one but an american
and no other american could have written
it and yet it doesn't come close to
telling the whole story of HL Mencken he
was as editorial writers liked to say of
themselves often wrong but never in
doubt but the surface consistency of his
beliefs was a theatrical illusion
produced by the self-assured crackle of
his prose this came as a great surprise
to me and I knew more about Menken than
most people do when I started writing
the skeptic I took it for granted for
example that he would be easy to place
on the political spectrum that he was
the pre-war equivalent
more or less of what we now call a
libertarian but as I look more closely
at his writings especially what he wrote
prior to World War One I came to see
that he didn't quite fit so easily into
that pigeonhole for the only state about
which he ever wrote without right
admiration was the Germany of Kaiser
Wilhelm in 1914 Menken wrote an essay
about Germany in which he described it
as a delimited aristocratic democracy in
the Athenian sense a democracy of
intelligence of strength of superior
fitness a new aristocracy of the
laboratory the study in the shop that
was man's idea of a really good state
and having come to the conclusion that
Germany was that state and was
everything America was not he proceeded
to say so repeatedly in his newspaper
columns assuring the citizens of
Baltimore that German notions of what is
good and bad what is right and wrong
what is effective and ineffective will
prevail in the world that was the
unlikely conclusion he had drawn from
his extensive but superficial reading of
Nietzsche he had come to believe in the
Victorian idea of progress only with the
German accent now how did mekin
reconcile his admiration for an
authoritarian state like Ville Amman
Germany oft stated belief in Liberty up
to the extreme limits of the feasible
and tolerable well for him there was
nothing to reconcile he explained it
this way liberty of course is not for
slaves I do not advocate inflicting it
on men against their conscience but this
was an intellectual sleight of hand and
did nothing to resolve the contradiction
so was Megan being disingenuous when he
later claimed to be strongly in favor of
what he called the sword of free
democracy visualized by Jefferson or had
he simply not thought the thing through
it's impossible to say though we know he
was not a liberal by which he and the
rest of his generation meant what is now
known in American political parlance as
a classical liberal we know it because
he said so on numerous occasions in 1923
for example he confessed himself to be
unable to make the grade as the liberal
liberalism always involves freeing human
beings against their will often indeed
to their obvious damage as in the cases
of the majority of Negroes and women on
another occasion he defined a liberal as
one who was willing to believe anything
twice
of course Megan wasn't a political
scientist nor does he appear to have
read and all widely in the classics of
political philosophy and intellectual
consistency was never his strong suit it
could be that he thought Jeffersonian
democracy was the best America could
hope for or that it was the necessary
precondition for the emergence of a
german-style democracy of strength and
it is also possible that he simply
changed his mind as he grew older
certainly he was deeply disillusioned by
what happened to Germany after World War
one and said so in print but the point
is that if you look to Menken for
consistency if you take what he wrote in
1922 and apply it directly to the
America of 2002 you may be in for an
unpleasant surprise this is the reason
why I don't much care for M watts and
don't write them myself I think I know
what make him would have thought about a
great many things if he were alive today
I think for instance that he would have
been very strongly opposed to going to
war with Iraq not because he was a
pacifist but because he was an
old-fashioned isolationist who thought
America should mind its own business he
thought we should have stayed out of
World War two and he said so in a way
that many Americans would find shocking
today here's a typical example a private
memo not for publication probably
written in nineteen forty-five or
forty-six and preserved in a file in the
closet of the Menken room I find it
difficult to work up any regret for the
heroes butchered in World War two anyone
silly enough to believe in such
transparent quacks as Hitler Mussolini
Stalin Roosevelt and Churchill leaves
the world little looser by departing
from it now I happen to think that is
dreadful stuff
possibly the most odious thing Macon
ever wrote in a long life devoted to
giving offense but am i absolutely sure
that it helps us to understand what he
would have thought of george w bush if
he were alive today no his mind didn't
work in that systemic kind of way and
because it didn't it's difficult to take
him seriously as a political thinker and
yet Menken still matters very much so
most of his major books are in print and
new collections of his essays continued
to be published read and quoted earlier
this year Richard Posner brought out a
book in which he served the web to see
which public intellectuals had been most
frequently cited there between 1995 and
2000 Menken was the sixth most cited
dead intellectual fewer times than
George Bernard Shaw George Orwell HG
Wells Timothy Leary and CS Lewis but
more times than wh on Berthold Brecht
Allen Ginsberg John Maynard Keynes
Lillian Hellman Marshall McLuhan I Rand
or jean-paul Sartre and if I may put on
my pop culture hat for a moment Megan
actually turned up on TV just a few
weeks ago on an episode of the WB sitcom
Gilmore Girls
a friend of mine happened to be watching
that night and another friend found the
script on the web and sent it to me one
of the characters in the show says I
have a surprise not only did I find that
copy of Mencken's chrestomathy that we
discussed
I also found a first edition of his
memoirs as well it's in my office if
you'd like to see them and his
grandchild replies oh my god I totally
would
now I ask you how many other major
American riders have been anointed as
totally cool by the WB more to the point
what other American journalists to the
20s continues to be not only read but
relished just one so why is it that we
still wonder what Menken would think in
what why do we still read what he wrote
about Franklin and Teddy Roosevelt and
Calvin Coolidge and William Jennings
Bryan part of the reason maybe the
biggest part is that he was mainly
interested not in individual politicians
or even in politics as such but in the
American national character for him
America was the land in which Puritanism
is constantly at war with hedonism and
analogously collectivism with
individualism and his great achievement
as a social critic was to isolate and
dramatize the struggle in a permanently
memorable way Menken's hatred of
Puritanism and hatred is not too strong
a word as the word he used is that the
heart of his critique of American life
he once spoke of the whole Puritan
scheme of things with it's gross and
nauseating hypocrisy 'he's it's idiotic
theologies its moral obsessions it's
pervasive Philistine ism all these
things he took to be intrinsic to
America's collective personality
theologies and ideologies come and go
but the conceptions of human nature from
which they spring are forever with us
and to leaf through Macon's work is to
be struck by how often as he bashed away
had long forgotten manifestations of the
Puritan cult or of the 20s he said
things scarcely less applicable though
in a very different way to America today
like this in the United States there is
a right way to think and a wrong way to
think in everything not only in theology
or politics or economics but in the most
trivial matters of everyday life thus in
the average American City the citizen
who in the face of an organized public
clamor for the erection of an equestrian
statue of susan b anthony
in front of the chief railway station or
the purchase of a dozen leopards for the
municipal zoo or the dispatch of an
invitation to the structural iron
workers union to hold its next annual
convention in the town Symphony Hall the
citizen who for any logical reason
opposes such a proposal on the ground
say that miss Anthony never rode a horse
in her life or that a dozen leopards
would be less useful than a gallows to
hang the City Council or that the
structural iron workers would spit all
over the floor of Symphony Hall and
knock down the bus the Bach Beethoven
and Brahms this citizen is commonly
denounced as an anarchist and a public
enemy it is not only erroneous to think
thus it has come to be immoral I should
add that he wrote those words in 1921 to
some extent
meccans survival is a triumph of style
but he was something more than a great
stylist if something less than a truly
wise man however perverse are excessive
his underlying ideas may be they
retained to this day much of their
impelling force and no matter whether
you agree with him about anything at all
you can't help being impressed by the
stubborn way in which men can the
self-made philosopher grapples in his
unpretentious take-no-prisoners style
with the permanent things the limits of
art the rule of law the meaning of life
the simplicity one comes to realize is
inseparable from the message in Menken
style and content are one and the
resulting alloy is more than merely
individual it is a matchless ly exact
expression of the American temper in the
eleven years since I started working on
the skeptic a great many people have
asked me something like this that's a
lot of time to spend with anybody
especially a guy like Menken do you
still like him do you still admire him
or did you get sick and tired of him
well I never got tired of him though
sometimes I got angry with him sometimes
I asked myself how could a man so smart
have thought so many stupid things how
could he have been so terribly wrong
about Jews about blacks about World War
two I don't have a simple answer to that
question people write books to answer
questions like that and the skeptic is
my answer
so far as there is an answer do I still
like him yes I do basically I would have
been very glad to have dinner with him
though I'm not sure I'd have wanted to
read what he wrote about me in his diary
afterwards for he was a fearfully
complicated man both cold and loving
opportunistic and loyal foolish and wise
much like the rest of us only more so
but as for admiring him the answer is
simpler not everything about HL Mencken
was admirable somethings about and were
frightful sometimes he's hard to take
yet there's no gettin around him he is a
fact of American life he was to the
first part of the 20th century what Mark
Twain was to the last part of the 19th
the quintessential voice of American
letters in the city of his birth he's
known as the sage of Baltimore a
nickname at which I have no doubt he
would have smiled but then perhaps he
was a sage of sorts though a completely
American one not calm and reflective but
as noisy as a tornado witty and abrasive
self-confident and self contradictory
sometimes maddening often engaging
always inimitable definitely a man to
have dinner with and a writer to read
for as long as books are read
thanks Jerry when we first knew that
Terry was coming here we cast about in
our minds who would be an ideal
commentator for this particular book
this particular biography I'm happy to
report to you today that we have in fact
engaged the ideal person to talk about
Terry's book PJ O'Rourke is the author
of many books and he is the Meccan
research fellow at the Cato Institute PJ
well it's very nice I'm sorry to say
that he didn't want to be funny before
me but I know better than to try and be
intelligent after him so I won't try but
the title of HL Mencken fellow unpaid
and worth it has to be something that I
in fact Oh personally to HL Mencken back
and I think it was 1989 ed Crain was
looking for a way to get me to I don't
know to increase my my donation to the
Cato Institute from five dollars a year
to ten dollars a year or something
anyway Menken's diaries had just been
published and making was at that time if
we cast our mind back a sort of icon to
certain right-wingers in Washington
wrongly I would say and and Terry would
would would prove if the editors of the
American Spectator had read their Menken
with attention they never would have
published the Vince Foster or abducted
by space aliens articles that cause that
magazine to go cur fluey anyway when the
diaries were published so uh the left
wingers were delighted to discover that
man can privately used the n-word you
know and the j-word and even called
women ladies and I love this sensitivity
to giving linguistic offence from people
who gather in Lafayette Square to shout
fu George Bush through bullhorns anyway
so ed thought this is my whole career
linguistic offense that I should be
chaos HL Mencken research fellow
I believe Menken deserves better
actually and and now he's received it
he's received it in in Terry and in his
wonderful book Lincoln is is remembered
as an iconoclast and a debunker and sort
of a permanent kick in the ass to the
boo Blasi proprieties and a little in
wat here it's a shame that he didn't
live into the era of fast food and
spandex because there would be so much
more boo Blasi asked to kick butt but
make it was a lot more than that he was
a pioneer and a revolutionary in
American letters if not in American
thought I mean first it's a pyrotechnic
use of specifically American language I
mean others before had written in an
American idiom but that idiom was
usually folksy as in the best of Mark
Twain and his fellow humorous or when
the idiom was not folksy it was baloney
like Henry David Thoreau or cracked in
the head like like Walt Whitman Lincoln
invented a style that was both wholly
American in its humor and its exuberance
but also fit for the expression of
actual ideas and thoughts even if some
of those ideas and thoughts were wrong
but more important than this revolution
in style was the revolution in tone that
that Menken fathered he was the first
journalist so far as I know ever to
employ the light touch when covering
serious topics I commend to you his
story about a 1917 attempted coup in
Cuba that he recounts see in heathen
days as an absolute masterful example of
the light touch
and he was also the first reporter to
turn a serious eye on the silly for
which his dispatches from the Scopes
trial the first are justly famous but
most important of all in the matter of
serious and silly Menken knew the
difference now here's an example from
his obituary of Calvin Coolidge which he
wrote during the Depression in 1933
Menken said of Coolidge he not only said
little and that little of harmless
platitudes all compact but did even less
the kind of government he offered the
country was government stripped to the
buff it was government that governed
hardly at all
thus the ideal of Jefferson was realized
at last Coolidge was preceded by one
world saver and followed by two more
what enlightened American having to
choose between any of them and another
Coolidge would hesitate for an instant
he had no ideas and he was not a
nuisance when when will we see another
politician of which that can be said
making a very sharp eye for piety 'he's
piety zazz versus beliefs
you see piety czar aggressive and our
piety zwi shower desire to to walk on
the heads of our fellow men or failing
to get on top of them to pull them down
to our level consider the difference
between piety x' and beliefs consider
the difference between an informed and
rational belief that an astronomer
astronomer might might have that an
asteroid is about to hit Earth in
consider difference between that and a
pious assumption that an asteroid will
strike earth now if you believe that
this disaster is imminent you set out to
prove the danger to test your proofs to
convince others by calm and measured
arguments that your proofs are true that
your tests are valid and that therefore
a certain informed and rational actions
should be taken you do not found
chapters of mothers against asteroids or
Lobby Congress for laws forbidding
asteroids the
strike the planet the tone that Menken
invented and I would call it for the
lack of kind of clever phrase that would
have rolled from night from from the
typewriter of the master I call it a
big-city smartass the Menken see Megan
was present at as Terry just pointed out
he was president ad we did not
coordinate our little talks
so cover a bit of the same ground here
but but more but Megan was president and
and keenly observant of and indeed in a
front lank rank leader in the great
transformation of America from a country
full of apple knocking yokel hayseeds
into a nation of urban wisenheimers you
know see our minds again as Terry said
Megan is so identified with the 1920s
that by which time that transformation
had largely taken place that we forget
how early it was that that Menken merged
1899 he was co-editor of the smart set
with George Jean Nathan
beginning in 1908 and I mean at that
time the members of the Algonquin Round
Table they were in nursery school you
know trading such witty quips as you're
a booger head you know I mean the big
city smartass tone that pervades all
journalism today was a Menken invention
that is to say we have him to thank for
lloyd grove and that brings me to the
one thing that i truly love about Menken
that he was wrong
throng rather often he's wrong about
germany twice in a row you know is very
wrong about theodore dreiser being a
good writer Menken's genius was so great
that if he hadn't been wrong a lot it
would be insufferable that he'd even
ever existed you know and as it was a
Menken lived to see the the urban
smartasses come to power with FDR and he
learned or at least I hope he learned
that there are worse Pyatt ease than
those of Apple knocking yokel hayseeds
I am though deeply gratified that Megan
was alive and
still alive and well to see FDR pushed
up the handicapped access ramps to the
gates of hell it is to me
obviously there are men can opinions
that one wouldn't care to be a fellow
traveler with but it's but but very
interesting to me is that men can
dislike democracy and all the more in
the wake of the New Deal's depredations
a democracy he wrote as a theory that
the common people know what they want
and deserve to get it good and hard but
what's even more interesting than that
to me is the is the fact that we
libertarians if we're to be truthful
with ourselves also dislike democracy
not that we'd replace it I mean I mean
the alternatives to democracy are
disgusting but just because we abhor the
oppression of mankind by one person or
by a few people there's no reason for us
to be happy and proud about the
oppression of mankind by a plurality of
people over the age of 18 not counting
votes in Florida Megan was acutely aware
of this and of the other problems of
lawmaking that cause us as libertarians
to urge our lawmakers to look upon
Calvin Coolidge and be as like him as
they can 72 years ago Menken wrote there
is in fact no reason for confusing the
people and the legislature the two are
quite distinct the legislature like the
executive has ceased save indirectly to
be even the creature of the people it is
the creature in the main of pressure
groups and most of them it must be
manifest or of dubious wisdom and even
more dubious honesty laws are no longer
made by rational process of public
discussion I would insert if indeed they
ever were they are made by a process of
blackmail and intimidation and they are
executed in the same manner the typical
lawmaker of today is a man wholly devoid
of principle a mere counter in a
grotesque and knavish game if the right
pressure could be applied to him he
would be cheerfully in favor of polygamy
astrology or
cannibalism well Bill Clinton was
cheerfully in favor of polygamy you know
we had astrology and Reagan White House
and George W Bush is eating his own kind
in the corporate corruption scandals of
the moment so we're three for three in
the just in the past twenty years
Lincoln was quite appropriately uh
so-called in the title of Terry's book
he was a skeptic but this did not make
Menken cynical and bitter as a person
rather it made him humorous and indeed
in a way at least in his personal life
if not his prose accepting making
embraced the full complexity of the
human character even one he didn't like
it very much and it's something that we
advocates of freedom should be sure to
remember to do we support freedom not
because men are good but because
individual men bad as they may be are
pretty amusing whereas men in mobs men
in gangs men in Congress are no fun at
all we should not fob off upon the world
the notion that if people were perfectly
free people would be perfectly rational
that people would always be full of
enlightened self-interest and never full
of crap we own an enormous debt to Terry
Teachout for taking us back to our
Menken we need to read mekin to to keep
ourselves from ever turning into
idealists he denounced idealist at great
length and a was at his very worst when
he attempted to be one and I think he
basically said all about idealism he
said an idealist is one who on noticing
that a rose smells better than a cabbage
concludes that will also make a better
soup well thank you
Thanks
as a typical in Aikido book form will
now have a question and answer session
for both of our speakers please raise
your hand I'll identify you and then
wait for a person to bring you a
microphone and also please identify
yourself and any institutional
affiliation you might have who would
like to ask a question in back
when he was trying to be an idealist and
that sometimes he was an idealist he
took a non skeptical approach to some
topics earlier that particularly before
World War one and when mekin was trying
to when he was writing in a more
explicit way about what he imagined as a
good state a state that work the state
that he idealized was the Germany of
Kaiser Wilhelm
he wrote very explicitly about this
although it's largely forgotten and in
any attempt to understand his thinking
one has to come to grips with this and
what it meant which I've tried to do in
the book he also he can be a bit of a
pulpit pounder at times and he's at his
weakest when he does that he is that way
in a book of premises the book he wrote
in 1917 about American literature and
American Puritanism sometimes every once
in a while and most particularly on this
subject and on the subject of FDR wankum
could forget to be funny he could forget
to be amused and when he takes umbrage
he sounds just like anybody else taking
over and Charlie with a better
vocabulary Michael Kelley the editor of
the Atlantic Monthly you know also
writes a column for The Washington Post
told me the thing that he hated most
about Clinton and he really hates
Clinton was that Clinton made him so
angry that he lost his sense of humor
and that would happen to make and I
would also say that Macon is generally
at its best when he's criticizing a
policy or cultural constructs that when
he offers an alternative this is
something you may have noticed around
your own house when he offers an
alternative you know I mean say for
instance Christmas when you'd announced
it to the children as being over
commercialized here on very sound ground
when you when you attempt to entice the
children into replacing it with some
sort of anglo-saxon version of
I mean you are on defender ice and as
Megan grew older he was he was much less
likely to indulge in that sin I think he
realized perhaps by instinct perhaps
even very consciously that he wasn't
good at thinking through desirable
alternatives to that which was bad that
the real the heart of his art as a
writer and the reason why he's alive for
us today
is because he is so stimulating when he
is speaking in a purely destructive way
of other things he doesn't like other
questions
Chris grebe I'm curious I've seen moving
the hair at the wind and I know the ek
Hornbeck character is obviously based on
HL Mencken is that a fair portrayal of
him and I guess is my question not him
personally and about the really savage
cynicism the ek Hornbeck chosen that in
that story
well it's naughty of me to say this but
a boy must peddle his book and there is
a lengthy section of my book which is
about the Scopes trial and Menken's
involvement in it which was quite up to
his knees he was involved with it in a
way that would now be regarded as
entirely unethical since he also covered
it for the Baltimore Sun about the
Hornbeck characterization it's clever
and I think I said somewhere in the book
that Megan must be the only great
American writer who was portrayed on
film by a great American dancer Gene
Kelly but it's a caricature just like
everything else and inherit the wind is
a caricature and here at the wind as I
talked about in the book deviates quite
deliberately from anything like a real
portrayal of what was happening in the
Scopes trial so it should be taken with
a stalactite of salt I think other
questions in the front row there Chris
Buckley congratulations on the book
Terry it's really wonderful he the when
the diaries were published about seven
eight years or so ago I think it was
that was when we first saw Menken sort
of unmasked as a bigot
the the n-words the J words in
particular how heavily has that cost his
reputation among in the predictable
sectors in a khadeem in in the left
intelligentsia and has it been effective
in deterring and steaming sales of his
of his books well those are two
completely separate issues in the first
case it has been
quite effective although even before the
publication of the Diaries I would
venture to say that mekin was the least
taught of major American writers and he
scarcely taught at all now
but it hasn't kept his books from
selling even though he is now regarded
as something on the order of is it is it
red kryptonite but his books sell there
in print they sell well nobody ever has
any difficulty cobbling together a new
anthology and finding a publisher for it
Menken may not be taught but he's
popular he's popular because he gives
pleasure he's popular for a lot of other
reasons because there's there's
something to him more than the beauty of
the style but the first reason why he's
still popular is simply because he's so
fun to read he's awfully hard to resist
unless you were totally humorous like
some of the people that I think you were
referring to in your question on the
aisle
who is the other voice from the 1920s
you referred to and said I said I said
there was only one other voice from the
1920s that had lasted as long
oh no I didn't I I may have misspoken
but what I meant to say was only one
makin other questions get on the front
row here I'm I'm the Petersons with the
Heritage Foundation is an adjunct and it
seems to me having read and devoured
notes on democracy in 1927 which
exploits democracy to the nth degree he
said in part it seemed to strike him as
malleable if not orgy orgasm at one
point in any event I think there's more
to democracy and I think it's very Hayek
in and Cato asked and deserves the
treatment that I got from my mentor at
NYU namely living from Mises that it is
a kind of a consumer democracy that we
would miss in the marketplace
indeed Lincoln
beside Mises contended we have a market
democracy or consumer democracy and
again and again and I like my the two
commentators if they would seek to see
the whatever kingship there may be in
opposition between let us say making on
the one hand and Mises on the other it's
interesting and good that you mentioned
notes on democracy Menken didn't like
that book but he didn't like it for
idiosyncratic personal reasons I think
it's maybe the most underrated of his
important books and I spent some time on
it in the skeptic for this reason
exactly I think it's it's defect and
this is something that PJ was alluding
to earlier it's the fact is that Menken
provides a brilliant critique of the
problem of popular democracy but at
least in the compass of this book and we
know because we read the rest of his
work as well
nowhere else does he really attempt to
construct any kind of possible
alternative to democracy he simply
spends this short and brilliant book
telling us very brilliantly
how dreadful democracy is but he hasn't
thought through the alternatives I am
NOT an economist so I I really can't
shed any light on on the differences or
similarities between Menken and Mises
Megan was himself a terrible economist
utterly and didn't really understand
economics at all but I think there's a
couple things it's always important when
we criticize people for having views
that we find abhorrent today for having
those views in the past this is not to
necessarily excuse the views but we
there is an anachronism in applying
modern knowledge to to pass thought oh I
don't think fully it was not really
fully evident until after World War two
and perhaps not really until the end of
the 50s or maybe even later than that
that there Rudy was no alternative to
democracy there was a feeling among many
many intellectuals in the middle of the
previous century that there must be some
better idea some more technocratic idea
some more some less sloppy some less
corrupt you know some less foolish idea
for governance and the experience that
we have had in how things have worked
out for democratic nations versus how
they have worked out for demo for
nations have had other systems
alternative systems has proven to us it
is crystal clear to us in 2002 that that
the of alternatives to democracy are
awful is not so crystal clear to a
person in the 20s and 1930s also when we
go back to a person as old as Menken was
at the time of his education it was not
known that the racial theories of those
days were completely horseshit it simply
wasn't known people didn't know they
thought they may have have agreed or
disagreed with the theories but they
thought there was some basis for the
theories and and we know now from our
scientific study and from our genetic
studies there's no basis to them
whatsoever that the variations in DNA
within a so-called race are greater than
they are between the races that these
are meaningless social constructs but
but that was not known back then and so
to criticize a person for taking racial
theories seriously you may criticize the
the
their unkindness their injustice their
their bigotry indeed but but to
criticize them on the simply on the face
of it for taking racial Theory seriously
is is an anachronism and so a lot of
Menken has to be read with the thought
that this guy was born a long long time
ago he would be what a hundred and
twenty one hundred twenty two years
that's right one hundred and twenty two
years old if he were on and I I would
take this opportunity to point out this
is one of the things that I tried to do
in my book to put Menken in historical
perspective and as regards the question
of race to me the interesting thing
about Menken is not that he thought the
sorts of things that one might have
expected a person born in Baltimore in
1880 to have thought but that he
published the writings of blacks like
James Weldon Johnson and George Schuyler
in the american mercury and indeed had
them to dine at his house his home in
Baltimore you can't there are things
about him you can't excuse but you must
take everything about him in historical
context which is the problem with a lot
of of the what we call the political
correct commentary today is that it is a
historical and has no historical
perspective at all there's also
something that trollop wrote in his
autobiography is said that if you give a
man a tool he will use it as hard as he
can if he is a man's tool his words his
words will run away with him and mingkun
who was a master of invective and a
master of offense given the chance to
exercise the invective and give offense
was not one to
to shrink a front front from the
opportunity he would use the tool as
hard as he could and so that there's
always I think his him as a person and
him as a writer I mean the dancer in the
dancehall that he wrote towards the end
of his life hilarious piece about
segregation on Baltimore tennis courts
when he gets into golf he's under
particularly marvelous ground have the
whole idea of taxpayer supporting golf
and for any person of any color just was
absolutely marvelous them if I may adapt
the punchline of a joke which I
certainly will not tell with the
television camera here the reason the
reason why Macon wrote the way he did
was because he could question down here
Bob Carlson the American civil rights
union how well did make him get along
with his bosses that owned and edited
the paper over all those years well he
was eventually he became one of them in
the second half of his career and his
son Menken sat on the board of the
company that owned the sunpapers
he did not like being an editor but he
worked at one at intervals during his
life last of all when he subbed as the
editorial page editor of the son and in
1938 and he was the labor negotiator for
the son in its negotiations with the
newspaper guild and was regarded as
being extremely good at that and
extremely fair at it some of the bosses
were his friends Paul Patterson the
publisher of the sunpapers was one of
his closest friends but he wasn't the
sort of person who reflexively sucked up
to the bosses that just wasn't his
temper at all question in the back
you know I'd like to Tom Palmer from the
Cato and sort of just comment that
minkins ad Romano filio in the context
of the time was less destructive than
that of Herbert Crowley or all the
progressives who went to Germany and
brought back two PhD one of the most
destructive recognized manga would have
agreed with you about that a man with no
college degree have a question about his
attitudes towards prohibition then and
now because he was a vociferous opponent
of prohibition do you think it was
because of his great hatred of the
puritanical forces who brought it about
his great love of beer or was there an
actual love of Liberty that was involved
in his opposition to Prohibition age a
trifecta of an offensive law you know
for somebody who you know is it just as
you described him and him there I think
Minkin had a you know there's a funny
side to German I'm about half German
myself and my mother-in-law is I was
most born and raised in Germany and so
I've seen a fair amount of Deutsch
philia around if I'm a mix foreign
languages you know in my own household
and there is a strange libertarian
little suspected libertarian streak to
the Germans as long as you don't do
things outdoors since is such a way that
it frightens the horses or offends the
neighbors or as long as people don't
know what you're doing it's okay you
know I don't think what other people
know that you're doing and you don't
there's a considerable latitude of
respect for private eccentric behavior
more so in in the German culture I think
then either the Irish or the anglo-saxon
a cultures which tend to be more
intrusive on one's private life and ones
indeed ones private thoughts Germans are
very rigid about their public behavior
above
rather you know things that happened out
of sight and I think that Menken had a
streak of that and back to a moment to
the to the to the the admiration and
liking of Germany this was a very common
thing right down to the minute that we
went to war or right down to the middle
of the first world war at any rate when
that when the when the torpedoing
started and so on
Germany was admired by people on the
left for the various social programs of
security workers compensation all that
kind of stuff
it was mired by people on the right for
being sort of a tidy and organized place
it was a brand new country it had that
there was a kind of admiration in the
1890s or so for Germany that would be
comparable to the early 60s admiration
for merging third world nations you know
for the way that everybody got all sappy
and kumbaya about Indonesia and so you
know back in in the early 60s and I
remember where I grew up in Ohio it's
very German area and I remember my
history teacher in eighth grade saying
she was a little girl during World War
one and she said she didn't know which
side we were going to go in on until
right at the last minute she said I
remember being perplexed because she
lived in such a German in America is you
know Germans constitute perhaps you know
next to the Irish at any rate the
largest ethnic group in the United
States and so the attitudes that he had
towards Germany were not so odd I have
to add something by the way which is
that in as regards the consumption of
beer and in nearly every other aspect of
his life
Megan talked a much better game than he
played he was really quite moderate in
his habits he's very funny about talking
about when when you should drink and
what you should drink this is all in the
book in his private life he was an
extraordinarily moderate temperate and
even cautious person this is the thing
that surprised me most in getting to
know him as a personality and writing
about him is that this this utterly
extravagant personality on paper was in
private
the mama's boy and chewed more of those
cigars and smoked them he sure did
because he was a lifelong asthmatic and
a good thing too those filthy five cent
jobs question in the back
Oh Gary Arlen and you mentioned Mark
Twain as the penultimate writer the last
and half of the eighth of the 19th
century do you think that Menken will
last a hundred years two or three
generations from now we'll venerate him
as much as many to venerate between a
hundred years later I hope so I think
they should and we're pretty close to it
now you know I mean Menken's earliest
published writings that that are still
red and anthologized date from around
1908 1910 he's coming up on the the
antique centenary not all of his work
will last he wouldn't have expected it
to he published by his own reckoning
something like 5 million words of prose
and he knew that a great deal of it was
ephemeral but I have no doubt that the
best of it will be regarded as classic
there's going to be a period of
adjustment and acceptance because he is
not taught at the present moment but he
is read and he isn't print and in this
area I think the market of culture will
make the right decision
also as I was saying in a little talk I
gave I think that he is such a core
constituent of modern tone the early
Minkin reads much more modern than late
Twain even though they they overlap it
really has a fully modern tone and it is
the tone that a lot of journalists a lot
of people who write for periodicals and
a lot of people who write for newspapers
and so on really cut their teeth on this
stuff so it is very much it's going to
remain accessible to the reader for a
long long time that's right but that's
the thing that throws you off because as
I was saying earlier
he sounds contemporary and he's not
contemporary you always have to keep
that in mind when reading him he did
indeed create what I think to be the
first great modern American prose
but there's sometimes a discontinuity
between the tone and the content
questions
aside from everybody who were minkins
greatest enemies where to begin Menken
himself with the collaboration of woman
who gained his wife
edited and published in 1928 a book
called a Menken terminus to maken skimp
lexicon I think it would be pronounced
which was drawn from his scrapbooks and
consisted entirely of things that have
been written about him that were
critical to the point of absolute raving
hysteria and it really was a clean sweep
he was he was disliked by editorial
writers in the Bible Belt a phrase that
he coined by the way he was disliked by
the editorial writers of the New
Republic at the time that the American
mercury came out he had an
extraordinarily wide range of enemies
and I don't really think you could
single out too many people in particular
could you do you think that's that's
that's a tough one
but the book is terribly funny to read
it's it's out of print but it's can be
found in libraries and it took a very
particular sort of fellow to edit that
sort of book about himself I think he's
quite proud of it Terry Teachout is
author of the skeptic a life of HL
Mencken it's published by HarperCollins
on the web at HarperCollins com next
week on